I was shocked in the documentary I
didn't know that you were born with this
birthmark on your face and then they by
accident they didn't give you anesthesia
and they literally hurt you so bad when
they were trying to burn this thing off
that it caused you to stutter yeah I
think it messed with my nervous system
yeah and then this whole story of you uh
being emotional about meeting Eminem you
would basically imitate Eminem and do
his rapping
it's a funny one that because my when I
was nine my I was going through all
sorts of speech therapy and when I was
nine my uncle bought me The Marshall
Mathers LP and he just said to my dad
this guy's the next Bob Dylan you gotta
let me listen my dad didn't really clock
it you know he was just like okay
Edward's gonna go and listen to that and
by learning that record and wrapping it
back to back to back to back my it cured
my stutter and I stopped you know
talking like that years later I've made
songs with Eminem now and we've we've
got to know each other quite well and he
asked me to play Stan with him at the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame I remember
getting the call for to do it and I was
shooting it was in the documentary I'm
shooting 14 music videos back to back
and I guess I was crazy I get the call
do you want to go and do Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame and it was on like my day
off from shooting the music videos and I
was like I can't say no I can't so I got
a plane straight after one music video
flew their song and then that night flew
back and then uh and it was really worth
it yeah this was his induction ceremony
this is it
how emotional was this for you I mean
hugely I mean he's like
it's different I think it's kind of
different with um with with Eminem
because he is quite reclusive and
doesn't see or meet that many people and
I felt the first time that I met him you
know I was super nervous beforehand I
got invited to a studio in Detroit and
I'm sort of sitting there being like Oh
is he gonna be like is he standoffish is
he and as soon as he walked in we just
started talking about like Marvel Comics
and stuff like that I was like okay
we're cool he I assume he knows the
story now they he totally yeah
stuttering totally I mean I've known him
now for when did we first meet 2017 so
um yeah six years and we've done three
songs together I've played with him
twice on stage and he's another person
that I really relate to in some like
because he also lives in his hometown
still and he's got his own ecosystem
around him you know all of his people
live there all of his family and blah
blah so I kind of relate from that point
of view and I think I think again
meeting people like him and talking to
him on a level makes you feel less weird
you know I sometimes feel like a bit of
a a zoo animal or an alien to sort of
like wherever
whatever happens in my life it's always
some there's some something that goes
around you speak to him and it's kind of
the same thing
foreign